I promise that you'll never find another
like me who's excited for Taylor Swift's
new music good cuz that's the name of
the song
[Music]
not only did Queen Taylor drop her new
single featuring Brendon Urie of Panic
at the Disco she also gave fans an
epically colorful music video the
feel-good tune is sure to be our summer
anthem ahead of the release taylor spoke
with robin roberts in nashville live on
ABC where she officially revealed the
name and the meaning behind her new bop
me is a song about embracing your
individuality and really celebrating it
and owning it earlier in the day the 29
year old singer unveiled a mural she
created with the help of artists Kelsey
Montagu which led to an impromptu meet
and greet with fans so it makes it more
fun for me to create music
knowing that the
care about little Easter eggs or clues
or hints t-swizzle started dropping
hints earlier this year about countdowns
and fans went nuts rumors started
swirling that a new album could be on
the way for well ts7 season is
officially upon us and yes we're ready
for it
[Music]
you